[Musique]
bonjour hélène frade bonjour damien au à
la une de la presse d'abord ce matin la
campagne de l'entré deux tours en france
après le premier tour des législatives
la majorité présidentielle est menacé de
perdre sa majorité absolue à l'assemblée
et au coude à coude ans et avec la nuque
l'alliance de la gauche emmenée par jean
luc mélenchon le camp présidentiel se
retrouve sous pression et tâtonne pour
trouver la bonne stratégie d'après le
parisien aujourd'hui en france qui
rapporte que la macro ni hésite encore
entre agiter le chiffon rouge et jouer
la crédibilité ou parler du quotidien et
prendre de la hauteur signe de ces
hésitations la difficulté à prendre une
position claire dans les
circonscriptions où la nuque fait face
au rassemblement national de marine le
pen au second tour ces atermoiements on
le voit agace beaucoup libération marc
macron sorti du fond le journal tient à
rappeler qu emmanuel macron a été réélu
à l'elysée en avril grâce aux électeurs
de gauche qui ont voté contre le
rassemblement national le désordre dans
le mot d'ordre indigne aussi mediapart
les maquereaux nist aime bien donner des
leçons de morale aux autres c'est même à
ça qu'on les reconnaît le site d'info
fulmine contre la mauvaise foi du camp
présidentiel qui a fait savoir qu'il ne
soutiendra aucun candidat du
rassemblement national tout en indiquant
qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'une consigne
nationale mais au cas par cas à
condition que le candidat de la nuque ne
soit pas anti républicain un terme qui
reste à définir un peu plus précisément
pendant que sa majorité cherchent la
parade à la nuque et emmanuel macron ils
ont des placements lisez en roumanie en
moldavie deux pays limitrophes de
l'ukraine mais alors que les quotidiens
allemands et italiens évoquent une
prolongation de cette visite à kiev
l'elysée citée par l'opinion refuse de
confirmer le journal relève qu il ne
restera alors plus que 15 jours emmanuel
macron s'il veut aller en ukraine en
tant que président de l'union européenne
en attendant ce déplacement en roumanie
sera liée à l'engagement présidentiel de
se rendre auprès de soldats français en
opération en l'occurrence 500 soldats
déployés près d'un port sur la mer noire
dans le cadre du renforcement du front
orientale de le temps des soldats qui se
retrouvent dans le nord de l'europe dont
certains ont opéré au sahel pendant des
mois ou des années l'armée française met
un terme à l'opération barque anomalies
dans un contexte de forte dégradation
sécuritaire au sahel on lisait notamment
au burkina faso après le massacre ce
week end de près de 50 civils à
certaines gars dans le nord du pays le
gouvernement burkinabè est décrétée 72
heures de deuil national
un deuil national de plus relève wakat
serra à l'armée en effet par la
multiplication des attaques djihadistes
au sahel paradoxe des paradoxes ce sont
ces attaques terroristes qui ont servi
de déclencheur à la prise de pouvoir des
nouveaux maîtres de ouagadougou souligne
le site d'info burkinabè qui se
demandent ce qui manque à cette junte
militaire pour sortir le burkina du
gouffre sécuritaire wakat serra qui
fustige par ailleurs la décision de la
junte malienne de se retirer du g5 celle
de contraindre barkan à se désarticuler
au mali pour se ré articulé ailleurs
alors que la force française voué aux
gémonies accablé des sept péchés
capitaux était jusque-là un épouvantail
pour les djihadistes dans la zone des
trois frontières où va le burkina le
quotidien le pays s'inquiète aussi de ce
que plusieurs mines industrielles
souhaite aujourd'hui dans le viseur de
ces groupes armés qui ont déjà fait des
centaines de sites de production d'or
leurs chaises garder aggravant ainsi
encore un peu plus la situation
économique du burkina faso qui est déjà
extrêmement dégradée mais à propos du
continent africain hélène on en parlait
dans le journal cette affaire qui est en
train de faire scandale notamment au
royaume uni ces migrants qui sont sur le
sol britannique qui sont attendus dans
les heures qui viennent au rwanda où ils
sont expulsés on voyait par le royaume
uni en vertu d'un accord récent entre
londres et qui allie n'abîme dependence
rapporte que le dernier recours en
justice a finalement été rejeté hier le
gouvernement britannique refusant de
revenir donc sur sa décision de sous
traiter ses obligations en matière
d'asile au rwanda en échange d'une
compensation financière ce marché est
indigne une partie de l'opinion
britannique notamment au sein de
l'église anglicane qui dénonce je cite
une honte pour le royaume uni selon li
hai
le journal précise toutefois que sur les
31 migrants qui était prévu au départ
seuls 7 devrait finalement embarqué sur
ses vols pour le rwanda moins d'une
dizaine de migrants renvoyés au
longtemps voilà précisément ce qui
indigne le daily mail le tabloïd
ultra-conservateurs se félicite en
revanche de cette décision de la justice
britannique d'autoriser ces déportations
on peut saluer je cite les juges qui ont
rejeté à trois reprises les demandes de
militants de gauche de stopper le départ
de ces migrants mais quelle farce je
cite toujours que seule une poignée des
130 migrants prévu au départ soit
finalement renvoyé voilà et dans le
journal de 9 heures en trouvera simon
wolfach notre correspondant à kigali
pour faire le point sur sur ces
expulsions on se quitte pas là dessus
elle avant de vous laisser filer damien
profiter du soleil je tenais à vous
mettre en garde contre la tentation de
profiter des beaux jours pour vous
adonner aux joies du trampoline de times
quotidien britannique fait en effet état
d'une étude indiquant que la moitié des
admissions aux urgences au royaume uni
pour les enfants de moins de 14 ans en
tout cas sont liés à des blessures dues
à l'usagé du trampoline une installation
certes amusante mais fort dangereuse
bref pour éviter les fractures et autres
entorses dernière je vous recommande
plutôt d'investir dans la chaise longue
c'est beaucoup plus sûr est beaucoup
plus agréable n'est ce pas ces temps de
canicule ça me va très bien comment
rebondir après cela je ne sais pas si
c'est vous dire au revoir et à demain
merci beaucoup à l'aide merci à vous
d'avoir choisi à france 24 le prochain
journal c'est dans une poignée me